[Music]
in future kicks news hmm
submitted by drip too hard Oh Nike is
releasing a $350 smart shoe that's worth
it is it like the Back to the Future
shoe you saw it
I know it's worth it because other shoes
that 350 bucks are it's just a [ __ ]
shoe yeah so this one actually has
technology to it so it's worth it what
does it do other one has a limited stock
so it's like collectible does it make
fart noises when you walk what does it
do cuz I'm gonna probably buy it because
he likes [ __ ] if you're too fat
there's a scream or something God God
God where are you John
son of a [ __ ]
of course you better have a nice skinny
black dude always itself tightens all
around your foot and that is just like
Back to the Future everyone it doesn't
allow your foot to shoes
I need it now
I'm an athlete for basketball no bro
you're broken already
well this makes me feel like I'm a
basketball coz I get the shoe it
comfortable oh oh that's crazy
you can dunk if you get these shoes
that's the sound when it's ringing it's
like a robot is the Back to the Future
shoelace up [ __ ] well so my fear is that
it wouldn't let my foot go and then it'd
be stuck with different malfunctions
like no let it go that it completely
keeps tightening and crushes my foot and
then I can't walk I know it's like a
horror story I got two feet like they
rebel against me like they make you walk
to the gym and that's some good
technology right there you program it to
go to the gym every morning and then
[ __ ] it makes you run on the treadmill
[Laughter]
it forces you to go to like things your
vodka program it forever yeah you talk
back to your parents it kicks you in
your faces you this is actually not the
first shoe that they have released that
is self leasing of course so this is the
second version of this so the first one
was called hyperadapt 1.0 this is what
it looked like Oh looks like the LA
lights
ugly they released this back in 2016 oh
[ __ ] way back then way back then now
these they are called a def BB a deaf
baby also back back the mall it comes
with its own app where you can adjust
the tight so it's customized well it it
has auto charges yeah oh god you gotta
charge your shoes how many homes how
many Ounces are these shoes I don't know
that's a good question is it waterproof
it is resistant to sweat so I don't know
about like puddles in a puddle I don't
know about that I mean if you have these
shoes and you're using ball you're gonna
do it indoor so and or ball shoot well
you don't walk to it the building that
has no so you do you wear your slides
and you keep it in because you don't
want you don't want you don't want rain
or dust in the rubber you want it to
stick I seem I just got this because of
volleyball we hadn't shoes yeah but you
see people lick their [ __ ] hands
yep that was me baby yeah volleyball
shoes are on my socks I would always do
this [ __ ] like I would wipe it like this
yeah but I don't give a [ __ ] in the zone
Pizza a set me shoes that order pizza
that's pretty no one sends me shoes I
pay for all my [ __ ] all right I was just
this one pair but they only made like a
hundred pairs so I was like okay I'll
take it and do you ever wear them no
bows are too scared to cuz they're 100
pairs worth like a $3,000 now because
what is such limited stock and so yeah
are they gonna say cuz you were scared
of ordering pizza no don't [ __ ] touch
those and wait there for 10 years then
we were like 10 grand I really all right
everyone everyone forgets about it no
they're not but they're cute I like them
no [ __ ] we're home I thought David
their City on I made a huge mistake of
selling a shoe a little too early and I
could have made like six more grand yeah
[ __ ] stupid dude I was like oh I'm
Marie Kondo my ass and I was like get
rid of it make some money off there and
now that she was worth like 5 grand if
you have that shoe in the wall I have a
lot of shoes I don't wear they just sit
there I'll have so many I didn't realize
like I just I have so many shoes well a
lot of people to learn they when they
buy shoes now because sneaker culture is
so huge they don't really think about
their outfit they think about the value
of the shoe so a lot of people have
shoes that are statement pieces right
but you got to build your outfit around
that statement piece because that's the
center of attention so a lot of people
do have their basics they just were all
thinking we're all black I do have the
outside but then outfit has to be dope
still there's some sayings yeah you
can't be wearing some like $3,000 shoes
with that's why you see like the Chinese
dudes would like the Balenciaga [ __ ]
dad shoes a [ __ ] you know they have him
your hair you have again that hot stuff
greasy but let's see I got shampoo is
what they need
oh I just got some shoes from REI
they're like they they feel like kung fu
shoes they're they feel really like
light and what they call food shoe I
always see them with their food barefoot
it's like yeah it's it's really cool I
just fixed your tongs dude I mean you
tie them up and it just it just feels
like really it just it just feels like a
[ __ ] I don't know it's it's like what
are you use it for like what do pyaza
for hiking climbing but those are toe
shoes it's it's so imagined toe shoes
without the toes separating so it's
really thin but it has a lot of teeth
okay and then it's just super
comfortable and I was like man I had toe
shoes oh my work poor belly yeah it kind
of reminds me of ballet shoes family
yeah when they sent on their tour points
oh no no they're called toe shoes but
the other ones that you spend anybody do
ballet yep I got to two point and then I
quit I don't know how people wear those
those Vibrams
outdoors or outside on concrete what our
vibes and the toe to toe shoes they hurt
so it's like I understand when you use
it on like a mat or some people were
like oh my god David so you wore Vibrams
in smile driving in your [ __ ] element
I put in my gym bag
I heard you happy to yield the endurance
up to this it's the most natural way of
walking so you got to start with just
walking a little bit here and then
didn't adding like start running with
them and eventually build mm-hmm because
we're so used to walking with shoes on
with clearly I can feel the cement like
a [ __ ] no not like that
I know I can't even walk around my house
without my slippers for real did you get
cold that is part of it but then just
feeling the floors make it I'm not
feeling the floor feels cannot it feels
what happened to you dude you're so
[ __ ] like [ __ ] pinky up now huh
Oh charity flow and then I take off my
shoes I'm like I should've brought my
slippers what about when you walk
outside on the sidewalk
you don't ever go out like when I think
where they wanted someone to take out
the trash oh thank God I could go walk
outside barefoot real quick without her
yelling at me you never wear barefoot
all grass it feels amazing
and I walk barefoot as much as I can
when I go out to get the mail
that's all barefoot when I go to get the
delivery food it's all fit
not when it's gravel I like being it you
grew up in a beach town everyone's just
barefoot in flip-flops yeah you know
that's why it was kind of really nice
when we went to Cancun and yeah yeah
that was really funny
every day but it fans yeah hard but she
wasn't barefoot in our room
she had her tongue closed hey yeah
exactly I don't have my travels so even
hardwood floors difficult for you
was that your job was don't like yeah I
don't prefer it what happened to you did
you used to be so [ __ ] gutter homie
no it's cuz you know what - it was you
whatever gutter I know I don't know what
you mean by that
well growing up I what I wouldn't get
yelled at for being barefoot like yeah
from Mexican households it's like that's
the opposite of Asia cuz they say good
for us at least a lot of the diseases
start with the foot yes I think you it's
like if they see you barefoot on tile
they think that [ __ ] enters your foot
you're getting yellow dye Kathleen do
that or catch a cold or get sick cuz
this cuz the floor itself is super dirty
and then now you're bringing that into
the house so you have your outside shoes
and then you have your indoor shoes I
see I got that in Chinese culture is my
culture where they always think you
catch a cold through your feet yeah but
then also following my - you telling me
your feet is so [ __ ] [ __ ] made that
you can't fight the cold of the ground
and as long as I [ __ ] you mom I was at
100 always was I can't do it anymore but
I like being barefoot me too it feels so
good because it's like when you first
touch dirt or like grass it's like ooh
it's like a connection Oh
your [ __ ] toes you gotta feel mud oh
you've never done what kind of sheltered
childhood I just told you oh my god
that's why when it rains I purposely
wear sandals
sound like so I can have the rain all
mics I could be in touch with nature I
ran outside barefooted I was like oh
let's go walk outside with I get
concrete and all that stuff though cuz
that [ __ ] does hurt if you don't if you
didn't build the talus for it because
you have baby skin right there but it
only takes some money laughs in the road
if it was but I want pretty feet yeah so
then they won't work but this white [ __ ]
okay I've worked on it yeah I know I
could walk on glass and I'm straight we
have a rule he can't put his [ __ ]
feet on my - on the front - cuz as soon
as he like slides if you don't it's like
a white mark oh my god but I got the
extra epidermis for the glass [ __ ]
forget hey let's meet
[Music]